hola una vez más nos habíamos quedado en
unos problemas que me pidió que
resolviera a mi amigo a casa así que
vamos a seguir haciéndolos ahorita me
estoy saltando algunos para no hacer
tantísimos vídeos pero los animo a todos
a avisarme si creen que hay algo de
estos problemas que piensen que me
falten bueno vamos a este así éste tiene
algo súper gracioso usa un lenguaje así
súper sofisticado para referirse a una
cosa que es bien bien intuitiva dice lo
siguiente usa el teorema de monótono
cidad para determinar cuando la función
es creciente y cuando decreciente a ver
teorema de monótono cidad teorema de
mono motor monótono con escribir lo
monótono ciudad y cuánta formalidad el
teorema de monótono cidad si mal no me
acuerdo lo único que dice es lo
siguiente nos dice que cuando la
derivada es mayor que 0 es decir cuando
f prima de x
es mayor que 0 entonces la función es
creciente creciente y cuando f prima de
x es menor que cero entonces la función
es decreciente y bueno porque me
incomoda tanto que usen este término tan
sofisticado pues bueno a ver que esta
derivada la derivada es la pendiente y
aprendimos desde secundaria que si la
pendiente de una recta es positiva
entonces la gráfica de la recta es
creciente y bueno de modo similar si la
pendiente de la recta es negativa
entonces la gráfica es decreciente la
única cosa que es diferente aquí es que
pues f no tiene una gráfica recta
necesariamente a lo mejor puede ser éste
una curva o algo así pero tener una
pendiente positiva nos dice que al tener
un cambio positivo en x tenemos un
cambio positivo en ye o sea es creciente
y de modo similar una pendiente negativa
nos dice que un cambio positivo en x nos
da un cambio negativo en jr
o sea queda decreciente nada muy
sofisticado verdad entonces quieren que
usemos el teorema de monotonía y that
para determinar
si la siguiente función f x igual a 3 x
3 es creciente o decreciente pues su
derivada f prima de x es igual a 3 es
una derivada muy sencilla 3 o sea para
cualquier valor de x 3 siempre queda
positivo es decir f prima de x siempre
toma un valor positivo y por tanto
usando el teorema de monotonía cidad la
derivada positiva nos dice que la
función original f x es creciente yo
creo que esto lo podríamos hacer desde
secundaria aquí tenemos la pendiente y
la ordenada al origen de modo que la
pendiente es 3
la gráfica nos tiene que quedar
creciente verdad vamos a hacer la
gráfica a ver nos quedaría algo así
ordenar al origen es 3 las pendientes 3
se ve algo así de modo que nos queda una
gráfica creciente en pues de menos
infinito de finito por seguir siendo
sofisticados vale en todo ese intervalo
ok estoy aquí pues tienes un montón de
terminología sofisticada para hacer algo
que creo yo es muy muy directo pero
bueno vamos a hacer un ejemplo que es un
poquito más interesante vale ahora la
función que nos dan es h de zeta
y hd z está dada por haber z a la cuarta
dividido entre 4
quiero copiarlo bien es menos 4 por zeta
elevado al cubo dividido entre 6
entonces vamos a ver si podemos
determinar cuando esta función es
creciente y cuando esta función es
decreciente vale lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es derivar a ver h prima de
zeta es igual a haber el 4 baja 4 se
cancela con 4 entonces nos queda set al
cubo si verdad 4 bajas se cancela con el
4 y el exponente baja en 1 - aquí
derivamos el 3 baja 3 por 4 nos da 12 12
dividido entre 6 2 el 3 baja a 2
entonces nos quedan 2 por z al cuadrado
ok entonces nada más tenemos que
determinar cuando esta función es mayor
que 0 y cuando es menor que cero
para hacer esto pues tenemos que traer
un poquito de nuestras herramientas de
álgebra y vamos a preguntarnos cuando
esta función es igual a 0 es decir
cuando se está el jugó menos dos veces z
al cuadrado es igual a cero factorizar
unceta cuadrada nos queda z cuadrada x
zeta menos 2 y queremos que eso de ahí
sea igual a cero entonces ya sea que se
está cuadrada sea igual a cero o bien z
menos 2 es igual a cero
entonces los puntos en los cuales se
anula la derivada son 0 y 2 o sea h
prima de 0 es igual a 0 y h prima de 2
verdad h prima de h prima de 2 es igual
a cero vale entonces tenemos que
determinar qué sucede en los intervalos
que nos determinan en estos puntos o sea
antes de 0 entre 0 y 2 y luego después
de 2 entonces vamos a ver pues que si no
tiene la derivada va vamos a tomar
algunos puntos por ahí para ver cómo es
el signo es decir vamos a intentar ver
qué pasa con h prima de digamos menos 1
va a ver entonces h prima de menos 1 es
menos 1 al cubo o sea menos 1 y luego es
menos 2 x menos 1 al cuadrado menos un
al cuadrado es 1 entonces nos queda
simplemente menos 2 verdad entonces
menos 12 y eso de ahí es igual a menos 3
menos 3 es negativo bueno vamos a entre
0 y 2 entonces digamos 1 tomemos h prima
de 1 h prima de 1 es igual a 1 al cubo
una cuba es uno menos dos veces al
cuadrado verdad es un al cubo menos dos
veces uno al cuadrado nos queda
simplemente menos uno ok eso de ahí
también sigue siendo negativo bueno
vamos arriba de dos a ver arriba de dos
que nos pasa
vamos a tomar tres digamos h prima de
tres es igual a pues a ver 3 al jugo de
3 por 3 93 por 9 27 y luego a 27 tenemos
que restarle 2 por 9 menos 18 nos quedan
verdad 27 - 18 es 9 y nos queda positivo
entonces que sabemos pues sabemos que me
estoy dando cuenta que este ejercicio va
a ser un poco más interesante de lo que
pensábamos porque la derivada la deriva
es negativa a ver
creo que no me estoy entendiendo ni yo
mismo mejor voy a hacer la gráfica para
ver qué está sucediendo
entonces la gráfica vamos a graficar la
derivada no la función por aquí queda el
0 entonces aquí nos queda el lg y lg y
htc está verdad entonces ahí nos queda
el 0 luego por aquí nos queda en el 2 y
lo que voy a hacer es graficar la
derivada es decir graficar h prima de z
esto lo hago pues el teorema de monoto
necesidad nos dice que entendiendo a la
derivada de la función
podemos entender si la gráfica original
es creciente o decreciente entonces va a
la izquierda de cero ya obtuvimos que la
derivada es negativa entonces viene más
o menos así luego que sucede pues no se
vuelve positiva fíjate que se vuelve a
ser negativa verdad entonces pues no
cruce el eje sino que hace más o menos
algo de
como se da pues algo como de este estilo
verdad como que como que sigue por
debajo del eje del eje z y luego cruza
el eje z en el punto 2 cómo se vería
pues si se vería algo más o menos de
este estilo verdad a quien 2 se vuelve
positiva y entonces tendríamos una cosa
de este estilo 6 y si estaba un poco
confundido pero si esta es la idea osea
viene por aquí negativo nunca cruza el
el el eje aquí en z igual a 0 algo más o
menos de este estilo luego queda por
abajo verdad estoy aquí es la derivada y
luego sube seguro positiva listo
entonces a partir del teorema de
monotonía cidad lo único que nos importa
es en qué intervalos la derivada es
positiva o negativa para empezar vemos
que después de 2 la derivada se vuelve
positiva así en todos los valores de por
acá o sea para z mayor que 2 o bueno
para ser sofisticados usando el teorema
de monotonía cidad para z mayor que 2h
es creciente
voy a escribirlo es creciente
mayor que 2 ok ya sabemos qué pasa
después de 2 pero qué pasa antes de 2 a
pues bueno este creciente pero voy a
hacer un poquito quisquilloso en z igual
a 0 tenemos una excepción porque la
pendiente es igual a 0 es decir justo en
ese punto la derivada no es negativa
entonces todavía hay que decir un
poquito más además del teorema de
monotonía cidad para poder concluir que
la función también es pues decreciente
en ese instante por así decirlo una
forma de ahorrarse esto es decir que la
función es monótona creciente lo cual ya
contempla el caso en el cual se puede
quedar igual un ratito bueno ya estoy
por pegarle a los 10 minutos y no me
alcanza para intentar otro ejercicio
pero creo que lo haré en el siguiente
vídeo espero que te haya servido y nos
vemos hasta la próxima